on August 1 2022 this small mining town
of Soledad in Ukraine had Apartments
buildings houses fast forward to January
10 2023 and it had turned to Rubble that
same afternoon a statement on the app
telegram surfaced claiming Wagner took
control of this entire territory of
solidar
but even though the Russian army has
been fighting across Ukraine for months
this message didn't come from them it
came from yevgeny pregosian a Russian
oligarch with close ties to Russian
President Vladimir Putin he started out
as a Kremlin caterer where he got the
nickname Putin chef but in 2014 he
became the head of the Wagner group a
covert Russian network with mining
companies political influence operations
and a brutal private military force
until recently the Wagner group was a
secret operation and claiming a public
Victory like this was rare but things
are starting to change
and the Playbook of this dangerous group
is becoming much much clearer
[Music]
in 2014 Russian forces annexed Crimea
and began fighting in eastern Ukraine's
Don bass region a year later soldiers in
unmarked green uniforms showed up on the
ground to support Russian troops they
were called Little Green Men but we now
know this was likely the first time
Wagner soldiers were deployed on the
ground
these soldiers have become pagosian's
Frontline agents for Russia's Global
strategy
they serve multiple purposes for the
Russian government but Chief among them
is to divert attention from activities
that the Russian government and the
Kremlin in particular doesn't want the
world to pay attention to that's Candace
Rondo a journalist who investigates the
Wagner group and Russia's strategy for
proxy Warfare one of the main functions
of the wagon group serves is to deliver
weapons and military services to
countries with which Russia has a
military technical agreement Russian law
technically prohibits its citizens from
fighting for money in foreign countries
but the opaque nature of the Wagner
group has allowed it to recruit tens of
thousands of soldiers mainly from Russia
generally speaking these are
hardened military veterans at the
command level and then kind of at the
sort of rank and file level those who
were not recruited from prisons tend to
come from you know Elite backgrounds in
the beginning you couldn't really
distinguish them but today the wine
group brand is completely recognizable
by their emblems their Insignia and
their online brand these guys now are
basically kind of like the McDonald's of
the Russian way of War
and this new visibility has given us a
better look at the three strategies they
employ to do Russia's dirty work around
the world
the Wagner group targets countries
experiencing long conflicts or that are
weakly governed or corrupt take Syria
which has been under authoritarian rule
for more than 50 years and in 2011 saw a
civil war breakout between the Syrian
government and anti-government rebel
groups to fight the rebels Syrian
dictator Bashar al-assad turned to his
Russian Ally for help shortly after
Wagner mercenaries appeared in Syria to
support the government forces
since then all these countries have seen
Wagner troops on the ground most of them
while going through periods of
instability this has allowed the Wagner
group and by extension Russia to expand
its reach to at least four different
continents in particular in Africa where
at least 18 different countries have
seen Wagner forces on the ground in the
past decade
[Music]
in these client states where Wagner is
operating a lot of the work is teaching
local militaries how to do kind of
reconnaissance and counter-insurgency
but often in a very rough way the Wagner
group generally does this by
spearheading brutal military incursions
like in Mali another prime target for
Wagner since 2012 Mali has been fighting
a jihadist Insurgency and has
experienced three coups in just nine
years two of the three coups brought a
Simi goita to power a russian-backed
president that remains in power today
for nearly a decade Mali had military
support from France its former colonizer
but in 2021 when France started to
withdraw its Army it's widely believed
Mali contracted Wagner troops to help
them fight against the rebels and secure
power
[Music]
Molly denies the deployment of Russian
mercenaries from the Wagner group but
satellite imagery analyzed by the center
for strategic and International Studies
suggests they arrived quietly in
December of 2021 and built a military
base and access roads by the airport to
facilitate their deployment one of the
biggest motivations for standing up a
ghost Army that nobody can quite
describe or Define the main purpose of
that is to make sure that the activities
that the people do are not seen and
cannot be traced and tracked but that
doesn't always work in April of 2022 a
mass grave in the Malian desert was
traced back to the Wagner group
they've also been linked to other
violent incidents in Mali including here
where they killed about 350 men in March
of 2022 a U.N report shows that since
Wagner's arrival in Mali the number of
Civilian deaths has increased by 324
percent and thousands more have been
displaced
[Music]
once the Wagner group arrives in a
fragile country and intervenes
militarily to help local dictators
backed by Russia the big question is
what's in it for them
[Music]
because they're so integral to the
military technical agreements they're
also part of a cycle of
debts and loans that are incurred when
client states of Russia want to you know
improve their armies in exchange for
those loans typically the Wagner group
through a series of shell companies will
get payment in the form of oil or gold
or uranium even which is exactly what
happened in Sudan a country that's been
under autocratic rule for three decades
went through a series of coups and is
now ruled by Sudan's military Sudan's
relationship with the Wagner group began
in 2017. at the time Sudan's then
president Omar al-Bashir felt his grip
on power slipping and met with Putin to
establish a new alliance with Russia
transcripts show he presented Sudan as
Russia's key to Africa soon after they
met Russian military vehicles like this
one were spotted on the ground
and videos of Wagner troops training
Sudanese soldiers surfaced on social
media in 2019 when al-Bashir was
overthrown in a military coup the
arrangement persisted proving just how
enmeshed Wagner troops and the Sudanese
Army have become and that's because the
Wagner group has a lot to gain in
exchange for providing weapons and
training the Wagner group operates gold
plants like this one where they exploit
Sudan's natural resources getting that
kind of high-value commodity that can be
quickly turned into cash through a money
laundering Enterprise is a big part of
the Wagner group Playbook but all of it
is illicit and illegal and Sudan is only
one example the Wagner group's illegal
mining activities span the whole
continent
the Wagner group's Playbook has
reportedly made pagosian a billionaire
and the group is now also a legal entity
with headquarters in St Petersburg
Putin has often denied links to Wagner
group activity but in recent months
pradosian has started speaking publicly
about his role like when he claimed that
victory in soledar it's drawn new
sanctions and increased scrutiny from
around the world and that poses a
serious challenge for Putin's regime and
Military influence across continents
foreign
[Music]
foreign thank you